russian forces have seized ukraine's
second biggest power station the
lahirskur power station is the latest
setback in the east and donbass the area
around the capital kiev has come under
missile attack for the first time in
weeks but in the south ukraine says a
counter-offensive is gaining ground
from the ruins of this hotel rescuers
pull a man from the rubble
alive
not everyone was so lucky when russian
rockets hit bakmut on thursday
the city in the donetsk region has been
hit again and again by indiscriminate
russian shelling
part of moscow's stalled efforts to
claim ukraine's east
but in the country's south keefe says a
counter-offensive is moving forward
the city of her son fell to russian
forces early on in the war
ukraine is now stepping up efforts to
retake it
keeve says has knocked out the strategic
antonevsky bridge
this would help isolate russian forces
on the river's west bank away from their
supply lines
there is significant damage to the
bridge and its structure
we think that the enemy will try to
repair it again
we are prepared for this and you will
soon hear about our next steps
posting on telegram an official for the
russian appointed administration said
the bridge was still functional
while referring to ukraine's armed
forces as nazis as is common in the
pro-russian camp
so what most of zorwan
the bridge is blown up everyone rejoices
but these are just illusions
none of the nazis will ever enter her
son
the destroyed bridge which you can see
behind me still exists and objectively
speaking this hysteria by ukrainian
nazis won't change the outcome
[Music]
the fighting over this strategic
crossing is more than just a war of
words ukraine says its forces will
repair the bridge eventually but first
they aim to liberate her son
let's take a look at some of these uh
matters with uh justin crump he's an
intelligence and security expert and ceo
of the intelligence consultancy sibling
welcome back to dw
let's start with that antonovsky bridge
how damaged is it how much of a problem
is this going to be for russia
it is significantly damaged i think
there's been some confusion people
looked images on social media and
you can see the series of holes in the
the top layer of the bridge um
and it's not immediately clear it's not
like it's collapsed or anything like
that but certainly when you speak to
structural engineers about it the
integrity of the bridge has been
severely damaged over that span and i
think the biggest proof is the fact that
russia is now using uh boats towing
pontoons with vehicles and supplies on
it instead of using the bridge so i
think just judging the evidence of what
we've seen today that's how they're now
having to cross the river
which certainly suggests they don't
think they're going to get it back into
operation quickly if they're having to
resort to that and as a kilometer long
bridge and the main route of supply for
their forces in the city obviously
that's um a pretty significant setback
for them and they only have two other
options as well and both of them are
damaged too so uh russian troops from
the 49th army on that bank of the river
probably um feeling pretty anxious at
the moment about their resupply
situation right and resupply has been a
big issue for for russian forces
throughout this conflict
absolutely yes and
that's been aggravated i think by loss
of uh ammunition supplies in recent days
with donated equipment um
last but we'll talk more about but you
know in this particular instance as well
um
they've been struggling to get uh
ammunition forward fuel forward they're
limited in the range of their trucks and
uh of course the more stretch it gets
the more it slows down russia's ability
to certainly to mount offensives and
we've seen that in the donbass
now obviously in hurston it's different
because they're on the defensive there
and and they will have built up supplies
in that area um and they've been moving
troops to that part
of the country to defend um but
nonetheless you know as you get into the
point that they're consuming more
ammunition food fuel that's now all
what's come across the river currently
by boat um and uh
pontoons and that is obviously cutting
down the flow substantially from what
they have seen previously
and and it does seem as though hassan is
likely to be the next big point of
conflict uh russia is sending
reinforcements there and ukraine talking
about uh trying to retake it
yes and ukraine's been talking about
that for a long period of time um
but they definitely seem to be building
momentum now towards a more effective
offensive in that area it's the obvious
place to choose the
river uh is at the back of the russian
forces there that makes it hard for them
to defend now we talked about that
situation before with the city of
several donetsk in luhansk and you might
remember ukraine defending that about a
month six weeks ago in the same
situation for them
at the back of the round sorry about my
dog noise um
at the back of the house he had the
uh from being at home this summer like
the uh they had that particular problem
there where they were in the back
the um the river was next to them and
they couldn't cross it so that's
something that the russians have got in
turn and it makes them very vulnerable
in person um
you know they they have these major
problems um again that that's the only
place they really have that at the
moment on the russian side and it's very
important for ukraine to take the city
and stop it uh potentially from having a
referendum in september where it would
join the um potentially vote to join the
russian federation what we think would
be a rigged election so that's pretty
important timing for ukraine at that
point to do that
another of today's um uh developments is
russia's capturing of uh this uh
ukraine's second biggest on the day that
ukraine talks about um providing the the
eu with power over winter um do we
presume this not to be a coincidence
um
no i think they've been trying for that
power station for a while it's been long
contested i think russia managed to box
the way around it um
it's interesting it is the most
significant non-nuclear power station in
ukraine but it has routinely been out of
operation due to its position in the
donbass uh and on the front lines um
and interestingly right at the start of
the war and this was already scheduled
but ukraine actually switched its grid
towards pointing towards europe whereas
privacy is pointing towards russia so um
the value of that power station actually
to to ukraine has certainly fallen off
um because they're now able to go on to
the european grids and and that's how
they've been able to make good the loss
of not only that station but more
importantly zapariza
nuclear power plant which is the biggest
in europe probably about twice the power
output of uh this older station in the
donbass that's been captured now so it's
sort of symbolically important but i'd
agree with you create an assessment but
it's it's a tactical game for russia
it's not a a big strategic thing at this
point
out of ukraine itself the the uk has
started several weeks of training for
the first cohort of up to ten thousand
ukrainians they say um is that likely to
to make a difference i i i wonder about
that the um why you would take them out
of the country to to do this rather than
than have them there and on hand
you know it's a very important point
because
it's not just about donating equipment
you've got to train people how to use it
and particularly as you talk about
ukrainian counter-attack um to do that
at a higher level actually we've seen
anyone operate in the conflict in terms
of using your troops and your equipment
together to affect rather than piecemeal
attacks
that we've maybe seen from russia and
the donbass does require a lot of
preparation so again it's not about
giving say 36 missile launches if you
can't crew 36 missile launchers you
might as well give them four that can be
crewed four more
so the training is vital and it taking
place outside the country is really
important because where training was
taking place in the country
those people could be targeted and it's
using up ukrainian
assets in training who could be on the
front lines
so actually the donation of trading
support away from the battle area allows
people to work harder on training
they're getting professional support um
it's not using up ukraine's experience
people training their new people
so that's been a really important
advantage i think to allow that to take
place and often overlooked when we talk
about equipment donations is that um
other part of actually being able to use
what you're getting and work together to
a better effect and i think the proof
for ukraine will be in whether or not
they manage to mount
an offensive rather than counter attacks
in in hersen itself and to what scale
that will be mounted at and how well
coordinated that is compared to earlier
in the conflict as ever uh very clear
thank you so much for for joining us and
giving us your time thanks to your dog
as well justin crump of sympathy
really thank you very much
let's talk through some of these
developments with uh michael desh who's
professor of international relations at
the university of notre dame in indiana
welcome to dw professor um how do you
read those two good to be with you thank
you how do you read those two big gains
by each side today ukraine bombing the
uh antonivka bridge in hassan and
russia's capture of uh the vogelheiske
power station ukraine's second largest
well i think neither of them are really
decisive in terms of military operations
that are turning
into a slow grind the bigger issue for
the russians in the donbas is to be able
to
push ukrainian forces far enough away
from the city of donyatsk to take it out
from under ukrainian artillery attacks
which are going on every day
uh conversely the ukrainians are making
a lot of the uh
supposed defensive to take back her son
um and they have struck the antoine
antonovsky bridge a couple of times with
highmars
attacks on the other hand the bridge
is not destroyed and there are other
ways over the river including a roadway
on top of a dam
about 40 kilometers
to the northeast and now uh
pro donets
television is uh showing video pictures
of uh the russian military building a
pontoon bridge uh across the river so i
think uh the uh ukrainians are
making uh a lot of the attack on the
bridge but it's not clear that it's
going to uh you know really materially
aid their ability to take back your
songs it's not decisive as you say and
and the two sides do seem to be heading
for confrontation in in hassan with
russia said to be redeploying troops
from donbass and ukraine gearing up to
retake it how do you think that will end
well that is going to be the real test
of the ukrainian military because they
will be on the offensive uh attacking
russian and russian
allied forces
uh who will be on the defensive and the
ukrainians have
not conducted an operation like this
successfully
and i think that they're
doing it
quickly because they feel the need to
show some progress on the battlefield
and i think you know if they achieve
some success uh they'll use that to make
the case that they can win the war if
they don't achieve success i think
they'll be arguing that they need a yet
greater infusion of nato and american
military technology okay and of course
the world is waiting to see whether this
agreement over grain exports can be
successfully implemented without bombs
falling or arms being smuggled into
ukraine how do you see that going
i think both the russians and the
ukrainians have a mutual interest
in
the grain moving out on the other hand
the russians want to make the point that
while they're willing to agree to allow
ukraine to transport grain they're not
going to slow down their attack on other
sorts of targets including targets in
port cities like odessa
and so what it suggests is that the
future of the war will be quite complex
with some areas of agreement whether
grain
or pow exchanges moving ahead
at the same time
you know continuing hostilities
occur
good talking to you that's very clear
thanks for joining us uh michael desch
professor of international relations at
the university of notre dame
my pleasure
you